one of the best things about being a fan
of jason statham is that he instantly
improves any movie he's in
good bad or somewhere in between the
magnetic british action star has been
cracking skulls and delivering
delightfully hammy lines for over two
decades
whether he's a snarling villain or
hardened hero statham has turned in
dozens of extremely enjoyable
performances since he was first
introduced as part of guy richie's
repertory of british tufts in the late
90s
if you're even a casual enjoyer of
statham's work then you've probably seen
him in the transporter and crank
and also as part of the impressive
ensembles and the expendables and fast
and furious franchises
he probably even caught his surprisingly
effective comedic work in movies like
spy
and gnomio and juliet but there are some
movies in the actors ubra that only
hardcore stands have state them are
likely to have seen
enter one of netflix's current top 10
most watched movies the 2013 action
movie homefront
there is a good chance the name isn't
ringing any bells as despite some
obvious draws like james franco playing
a character named gator wynonna ryder is
a hardened criminal
and of course statham himself the movie
never made much of a splash
whatever you're thinking rethink it
but as so many films have in the past
it's getting another life thanks to
netflix
here's what you need to know about this
overlooked jason statham action thriller
after a violent drug raid gone bad and
the loss of his wife dea
agent phil broker decides to take his
daughter maddie and retire in what he
believes will be a quiet louisiana
parish
unfortunately it's not long before
broker learns that not all of his new
neighbors are interested in rolling out
the welcome wagon
after an altercation with some
schoolyard bullies broker and maddie
land on the radar of local meth kingpin
gator his desperately addicted sister
cassie and his vicious right-hand woman
cheryl what starts as a game of
intimidation quickly escalates when
gator learns that broker isn't just some
new guy in town but a retired dea agent
and broker decides to put his old job
skills to work to try and dismantle
gator's operation
both sides find themselves entrenched in
a violent back and forth
broker may be outnumbered but when gator
and cheryl orchestrate the kidnapping of
maddie he taps into a well of fury that
the small town criminals couldn't have
understood the depths of
unfortunately for them now that they've
crossed the line there's no going back
here's what you need to know broken
you have got my attention son
statham has rarely met a group of
fictional malicious criminals who he
hasn't wanted to kick the dirt out of
but when it comes to homefront there was
another big pull that helped bring him
on board
the movie was written by statham's
expendables co-star and oscar-nominated
screenwriter sylvester stallone
as statham told den of geek he's one of
the great writers
i think people forget how many great
films he's written you know he wrote
cliffhanger he wrote all of the rockies
all of the rambos
all of the expendables films it's like a
library of mega success
in fact when stallone first wrote the
script which is based on a novel of the
same name by chuck logan he intended to
star in it himself
when it came time to actually make the
movie however the legendary action star
tapped statham to take his place
while speaking with den of geek statham
said that getting the call was quote one
of the biggest privileges you can get a
hand-delivered script for something
stallone wrote for himself
critics also found plenty to enjoy in
the movie which was summed up by many as
simple but satisfying
noah burleski writing for the atlantic
said that as a big dumb action movie it
works pretty well
overall homefront delivers the enjoyment
you'd expect from a shoot em up
manola dargas of the new york times
summed up the experience of watching
homefront by calling it indefensibly
enjoyable
andy lee of the daily star said nobody
can write this stuff quite like stallone
and nobody from this over drama schooled
over botox generation of movie stars can
play it like statham
you can judge for yourself by checking
out homefront on netflix
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one